good morning taking it nice and slow
today so we're making this morning a
kid's day and uh we saw on google maps
that there was an aquarium nearby and
we're like hey we should probably go
check it out there's probably way more
fish and sea animals that you can see
here that you can't see in california so
we're at the aquarium
by the way
everything
still looks insane
looks like paradise everywhere
doesn't matter where you go
like they might as well tell me that's a
jail and i'm like yeah right
how much it actually is
what's that mister
okay and under mr coral judy
okay what do you see mister
[Music]
whoa
oh look at all this fish
look at that big fat fish
that i don't know
maybe a sea urchin
i'm not sure
that's awesome
hey monkey
this is what papa sees when he goes
snorkeling oh yeah do you want to go you
want to go snorkeling later no
okay
he's like why would i go snorkeling if i
could just come here
look at that monkey look he's eating
yeah
wow look at that she looks beautiful
wow look at that fish this is a cool
pattern yeah
that's the same fish that i saw earlier
yesterday remember i showed you a video
of a puffer fish yeah do you remember
no oh good
hey
why does this guy look like someone i
know
octopus
that's how they catch octopus yeah what
is that thing so there's a cowrie shell
right on top of it so they they like to
eat cowrie yeah and so if you
there's a whole like story about like
how long time ago like the calorie like
like trick the octopus so whenever they
see it they want to attack it so they
made a lure and then like you put it in
and it'll wrap around and then you put
yank it out and there's octopus that's
cool with the hook and everything it's
pretty neat
yeah
that one's like a nut taika so a little
fishy goes in there and you trap it and
then they can't get out
yeah then you eat it
just like that yeah yeah that's like a
maui's hook and moana remember he had a
hook remember that movie
remember that movie from like
from long time ago like a year ago how
long
he's like go this way it's like half his
lifetime
look how camouflaged this fish is oh you
pay attention right watch check it out
it's right there
you can't even see it huh but when you
come closer
there it is you see it that's the
outline
this guy's camouflage so good far away
just looks like nothing
it's crazy
wow
jellyfish look at that different kind of
smart cause we're not talking crazy
that's pretty smart
well look how these are that's really
cool i can't swim like that it's clear
they're different tomorrow
i don't know if you can see it
okay there's another big one in the back
do you see him you can see his body oh
yeah i see his body in there look at it
squirming around
okay it's crazy looking huh
whoa that one that's a zebra mori i
don't see him do you see him he's really
dark though like that
oh
that's a big old fish
holy moly
that fish is here
that's big
[Applause]
yeah you can stay right here you can see
that's a big old fish
oh my god are you coaching
the water
look at the [ __ ] look look
made me so nervous wait things that fall
in the
water that's how this works
[Applause]
you can sit down right there all of a
sudden he's brave with the water
wow look at that what is this look at
the one right here
right up front
he's looking right at you look he's
coming whoa
they look like dragons bro wow that's
cool look at that that is so cool that
is insane camouflage
look at these glasses
there's
this looks made up like god was like i
have some leftover parts let's create
this that thing is crazy
do you see what color dots they have on
them
good job
what about these guys they're silver do
they have blue spots too yeah yeah these
guys are as big as your head dude
okay this guy's looking at you
say hi
he's not saying hi what about his feet
his fin is waving oh his fins waving
yeah he's like this look he's waving
high it's like this
hey look at this one
that was stingray how did you know
you're a smart guy huh
hey mama
hey mama
there's a stingray whoa
black and white it's beautiful
and there's one of them
there's a arowana up there
look at the cuny mama bird
and the baby bird
that's the baby tucker bird
that's cuny
hey monkey guess what's going to happen
right now
yeah not just any shave ice
big one the size of your head
like that big
[Music]
where do you see it what do you see
good job
that's so good that your chinese still
you don't remember chinese
mommy me
wow there's so many mommy's in here
and carefully hey you can't just cut me
off like that come here come here duty
so all the flavors of the shaved ice are
over here
and you got a ton of flavors what's also
pretty cool is you can get regular food
on this side too i have a straight up
menu hawaii's favorite kitchen so you
get poke plates and all that and down
here you can see that they got like
garlic shrimp and even
which is awesome
you've seen that before you seen them
make shave eyes like that before
no way jose look at that
rainbow what kind of rainbow is that
what really
isn't there yellow
yellow what about orange
orange green
green
red
there's two reds in there there's two
bands of red
three oranges
look he's making ours now it's gonna be
so big
that's mine
oh
we're gonna share it duty i want some
that's gonna be a big one
is that big mister
um
does that look yummy dude
you learned that this year
yeah
good job what about red and red and
yellow
thank you what flavor is that one
mango
lemonade pineapples three of them three
flavors in one is it good
you wanna you wanna
ready take skills to eat a big one like
this
look at the green
try the green one yeah different flavors
is that yeah
which one's your favorite flavor so far
our color
the red one
no rainbow rainbow
what's
i have soft enamels in my tooth
[Music]
same thing i have to push it against the
roof of my mouth
this guy has zero problems with his
little mouth
he has a lot of problems with that mouth
mm-hmm
we're about to head to the beach now
but before we go they're stopping by
zippy's
a hawaiian staple
to grab some bento boxes so you can eat
on the beach
chicken mix what are you looking at this
bun
whatever that looks pretty good that
looks pretty good too
oh that looks
got some fried chicken up in here too
so my bear is riding with nancy now
to keep her company
and we're just cruising to the other
beach but as we just drive around
it's like oh my god
it just looks insane everywhere we go
looks like a straight up screensaver
so right now we're on the east side of
the island
and almost all the other times i've been
to hawaii i just completely shut my
brain off like i just go straight
so i don't know where i am or anything
like that and usually i let joe or david
take the wheel because they like to plan
stuff so i'm like okay anything you guys
want i'm down for anything but i
literally do not know where we are i
don't know north south east west any
type of orientation or anything like
that wow look at that water
wow
that sailboat
dude looks like someone hired it to put
it there that make it look beautiful
but this is the first time
where i'm actually like literally taking
the wheel
planning what we're gonna do driving
around and so i'm starting to get like
my bearings of where everything is on
the island like north south east west
and so far i think my favorite part of
oahu
is the east side like
not in terms of like tourism but like
let's say if i were to live here wink
wink
because you know my track record was
forever homes i'm just kidding no but if
i would i think i would like to live on
the east side because it's really chill
very suburby kind of reminds me of maui
a little bit
where it's not so touristy and then it's
like the streets are a little bit
cleaner a little bit wider and the
energy is less hectic because when
you're out in waikiki it's crazy it
pretty much feels like santa monica like
waikiki feels like it's attached
to downtown l.a almost except it has
palm trees and beautiful blue water you
know but when you go to the beach
there's like one sun umbrella after the
other so it doesn't feel like um the
relaxing like hawaii that i know or like
even like if you watch the old like
uh wedding vlog
or the wedding video we got married but
this side the east side like it feels
super just slow
and chill
coco head elementary
and i really really like this site
obviously the north shore has a lot of
beautiful beaches as you guys saw in the
last two videos that's where a lot of
the bomb food is
but this side feels very very like my
speed
and i really enjoy it
dude
look at this view
i'm just on a freeway too is this
insane
or what look at that holy
look at this
wow
wow look at that this is incredible
look at that man
wow
wow look how blue that is you see how
blue that is
wow
we're gonna jump in that ocean right
there are you ready to swim no i don't
want to go going to jump in we're just
going to close our eyes just count to
three one did then just jump right in
there
what do you think about that no no i'm
just kidding we won't do that that's
crazy boats
because that water is rough but oh my
god it's beautiful oh there's someone
swimming down there
that is beautiful
wow look at that man look at that water
it's like turquoise
wow
so i believe the beach we're trying to
go to is down there yes mister like
you're going side by side like that
so we're going to be hanging out in that
cove down there
you're right there
that's gorgeous let's go it's beautiful
huh
i love on this side this side's chill
the little adventure monkeys on the
loops
hey you little adventure monkey you
climb out by yourself
that's cuny
that's cuny
i like seeing them
a little jungle book don't pick your ass
please
and you go all the way down and there it
is
kelowna beach
this view is incredible dude look at the
two colors of the ocean
oh my god and then the white sand
look at that and that was the view from
the drive
wow
[Music]
be careful
i cannot get over this view
this is incredible wow
look at that
look how cute this is taika made a
friend and they're searching for
seashells together and does he keep
picking his ass
boy you better stop picking your ass in
public dude
wow
so that's where we're at that green tent
with my bear and nancy
and that's the young tykes and his buddy
and this
is the cove
look at that water
that's the outer edge of the coal right
there
isn't that beautiful
what's cool is they also have like that
lifeguard foam with the rope
so in case anyone's in trouble you can
grab that real quick because
the water here is pretty rough
so you gotta float with caution
wow look how big that crab is
that thing is huge
that's so cool it's about the size of
maybe like half my palm
i think that's the biggest wild crab
i've seen
that's so rad
so i climbed from there
all the way over here to the other side
earlier i was over there and look at
this view
holy
look at that
that is incredible dude
just rocky
waves crashing
look at that dude
insane
so beautiful
and that's just
open motion right there
[Music]
here we go guys
holy [ __ ] as soon as i jumped in
my worst nightmare happened
i snorkeled up here
the part that uh prevents water from
coming back in
broke so i'm trying to suck in air and
it clogged up
so i'm gonna take my whole mask off
and reconfigure it
and good thing it works now see watch
so thank goodness but that was freaking
crazy that's never happened to me before
i think it's probably gonna do snorkel
all right got back out from snorkeling
and i'm so proud of this little duty
look how comfortable he is in the water
now
good job duty
good job mister
are you scared now or no
you're a mr brave guy huh
are you making a little sand castle
to kill the ocean waves
tastes better on the beach huh
what'd you get mister
spaghetti
oh yeah it didn't come with the meatball
oh you want a meatballs i don't even
know if they have meatballs
they just they just smashed it yeah it's
meat sauce
oh what do you got you got fried chicken
oh yeah baby some fish yeah cherry beef
mac salad and chili oh i should have got
the zip pack deluxe
i don't know what came with all that
there's water right there mister you
could drink some
okay i can't drink that that's salt
water
it's not gross
that's mother nature right there
that's mother nature you buzzer you
drink it then yeah
are you used to this kind of language
what is going on i don't know
he's my son so i expect these kind of
things
no you can't be from my foodie hoodies
dinner time now and we've been craving
veggies like crazy we've been eating a
lot of bomb food
breakfast bomb hawaiian food but
unfortunately in hawaiian food there's
not a lot of veggies you got katsu you
got calobi you got loco mocha got all
that stuff right so oh we need some
veggies just to like make sure our
digestion is good and it just feels
healthy and we're like what should we
get we're like oh let's get some shabu
shabu so we found this place called
asuka
that's not very short for that that sumo
stew that i like so they might even have
like the
sausage theme that i like so we'll see
wow look at these soup bases they got
the asuka classic
which is a sake soup base with history
spanning back 1300 years the rich creamy
soup made with blending miso
spicy asuka pie tan spicy garlic
i got some yummy ribeye i'm not sure
it's some extra rib eye
and also
got taika his favorite udon
and i mixed in the radish and the green
onion did you get onions did you get
garlic in there no you got garlic in
there
i asked her for some gardening well
you're not trying to make out tonight or
what no at all i'm trying to keep the
vampires and the thirsty husbands away
so you're only gonna do blow drops
that's awesome
i love your attitude
my brother is back
ah spoiling look at that oh man
all right little you little hungry guy
what you got veggies going
i'm gonna
cook my
my meat
medium man
do you think you would still enjoy um
shabu if they were cooking it for you or
is this like the whole experience oh
yeah i just like this
because i feel like this is the whole
experience right like you wait for it
you get it the way you want it
a lot of meat
and some ponzu
what an awesome day and you know it's an
awesome day
where marbur could just lay there
and i do all the work like put our son
to sleep
what do you have to say for yourself
that's an awesome day
no you know it's an awesome day when we
have a ton of fun
me helping taka find a ton of seashells
and look at this guy
he is out
before the lights are out
and his little cuny bushy
my cuny little
potato goodnight everybody see you guys
tomorrow